so yesterday we spent some time talking
about Sean McVeigh who believes that
while the Rams were preparing to face
the Patriots in Super Bowl 53 he didn't
work smart that that first week during
the two-week window to get ready to face
the Patriots spent too much time
studying Patriots film didn't self scout
himself as much as he should so that
leads to the question today you're
getting ready to play Bill Belichick
which coach quarterback combination
Chris do you want as the two guys who
are working together to prepare to try
to take down the Patriots well gosh I
think there's probably they're the one
that steps out them them or at least
jumps out to me the most is Pete Carroll
and Russel Wilson first off I think I
believe and I'm pretty sure I'm correct
here they're two in one career you know
Brady and Belichick versus Wilson and
Pete Carroll I'm pretty sure that Wilson
and Pete Carroll got the two-to-one
advantage with the one loss being in the
game that everybody really wanted to win
which is a Super Bowl so of course the
Patriots have bragging rights there but
I look at either them or Sean Payton and
Drew Brees it's one of those two I mean
that's one thing I look at the Super
Bowl last year and just go man we were
cheated out of Brady Belichick and Brees
and Peyton which would have been
unbelievable game gamesmanship
storylines game planning everything to
where I think we would have saw a more
exciting game the Saints we're in the
Super Bowl I'll say that much yeah you
know and for me it's pretty easy because
we have seen the Patriots lose and the
Super Bowl within the last year and a
half the Doug Peterson and Nick falls
now that can't happen because foals is
with the Jaguars but how about the
Peterson and Carson when I'm with you
right yeah I that that would be a number
one for me and then I you know foals and
Doug Marrone wrong that falls in John D
filippo really because he was part of
that combination that got the Eagles
over the top when they faced the
Patriots in the Super Bowl so you know
any time where we have seen in the past
and ability to knock off the Patriots
and it doesn't happen very often
I'd have faith in it well yeah it's
teams that we talked about yesterday you
got to have creativity you got to be
really disciplined in big moments to not
mess up situational football and that's
why Tom Coughlin and the New York Giants
pulled it off that's why
the Baltimore Ravens have pulled it off
up in New England on the playoffs
because Harbaugh and Flacco played that
type of ball and they weren't afraid to
take some chances along the way right
just like we saw from the Eagles in the
Super Bowl a few years ago that's where
I look at Frank Reich and the Colts with
Andrew Luck I go that could be dangerous
here real soon but you know Peter said
in Moroni I do think of the type of
mentality are the right type of
mentality to met to match up with a Bill
Belichick and they're not afraid to take
some chances and play aggressively and
yet they can coach their teams in a
detailed manner enough to where yeah
they're good at the end of the half and
the end of the game and you know
important third downs and all that stuff
to where they don't shoot themselves in
the foot which happens a lot when teams
play New England how about Adam GaSe and
Sam darn 'old yes potential Patriots
killers right we've seen the the
Dolphins compete adequately in recent
years with the the Patriots and gase was
the coach the last three seasons and
Arnold is you know potentially young
franchise quarterback a guy who's got
the arrow pointing up maybe that's a
combination that well we know we're
gonna see it twice a year well you know
find out whether or not the combination
is gonna work well yeah and I mean GaSe
has already shown us that he can do it
though you know just to like what we
were just saying and then you mentioned
you know Marone and Frank Reich and in
John Dee Philip Lowe and all those guys
hey you know we've seen it in in that
matchup already with gays I mean they
they beat the Patriots two years in a
row at home down in Miami because they
were aggressive and you know good game
planning and played tough physical
football I'll tell you another name that
deserves to be on the list at least
because they're to know in their career
against Brady and Belichick is Ron
Rivera and Cam Newton again there's
another River Boat Ron not afraid to be
aggressive Cam Newton a big guy who does
a lot of different things to your scheme
to where it stresses a guy like Bill
Belichick out because he goes oh I want
to play this defense but oh I gotta
worry about this because Cam Newton does
this oh I want to play this defense
against this formation but oh gosh I
can't do that because Cam Newton will do
this to me so they've shown their
ability to be a pain in the butt for the
New England Patriots too but if you made
me pick one I guess I'm still going Sean
Payton and Drew Brees right what is it
what is your one if you got to pick one
I got a
to your head and you got to pick it
Peterson and Wentz without question
you're gonna be okay because because
we've seen what Peterson can do yeah and
and Wentz right now I think has the
overall better physical abilities we
just spent time talking about Drew Brees
being in decline yeah no I know I trust
and I'm not trusting a limited Drew
Brees against the Bill Belichick defense
because he will know exactly what Brees
can and can't do he will dare him to do
the things he can't do he won't be able
to do those things and the Saints will
be able to do nothing against a Patriots
defense and that's my thought yeah
that's that's I listened as you're
saying that you you might make me
backtrack a little bit I'm not so sure
you're not right about that one I hate
to admit it but how dare you have an
intelligent football thought like that
what a jerk hour how about Frank Reich
and Andrew locked out I don't know
Andrew Luck with the kind of coaching
that that that Ito's DNA the guy who was
there running the offense when the
Eagles beat the Patriots you know that
they had that game last year on a
Thursday night that was the blowout but
the Colts kept making it interesting I'm
anxious to see those two teams come
across each other again because I think
the Colts could make it you know the
rivalries back on remember when Chris
Ballard said that yeah I think the Colts
could make it interesting if they get a
chance to play him again I do too you
know how you got a great offensive line
and your luck who's aggressive and then
you said it Frank Reich cos he showed us
last year that he is a master game
planner and he can come up with four or
five plays every week that can just
absolutely scorch a defense for big
plays and with the talent they have on
that football team and Andrew Luck's
ability to throw the ball down the field
yeah I'm with you there
in fact you you made me second-guess
with your thing about Drew Brees and
Sean Payton to where I'd like to change
my vote to Frank Reich it in too late
you took your hand off the checker oh
it's late what do you think you're Alex
Trebek and jeopardy over your shut up
I'll do what I want I'm changing my pick
you've completely changed the game all
right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports